the main stage is going to be with Brian
when he comes up and talks about how he
built the Airbnb culture so you're here
you I've been following the
presentations and so now you know how to
get started you built the team you
started to sort of build your product
it's off the ground it's growing people
love it you figured out how to do that
you figured out how to create a very
special one in a kind company with
monopoly powers that's big and the
market that you're chasing after is
slightly bigger than the paper airplane
business so you're good right so now
what so we're here to submit that
actually culture is the thing that's
going to be very very important for you
to be able to scale the business as well
as your team and hopefully after this
talk you'll be able to know what what is
culture why does it matter how does sort
of create your core values and think
about elements that sort of fit together
four core values and the culture that
create a high performance team and get
some best practices for the culture so
what is culture anybody have a want to
take a guess at what how one should
define this dizzle values yeah that's
good
could you look that up on the because
you had a computer and internet
connection you just look it up so these
are some definitions that you'll find in
in Webster's dictionary and but that's
that we're at Stanford this kind of a
trick question it's the CS class he
questions are never straightforward the
real question is what does company
culture going to be you know culture
that we can generally talk about society
about groups about places or things here
we're talking about company culture and
so how do one define company culture we
can take the previous definition and
modify it a little bit and so everything
this is a hint of how we may want to
define company's culture every day blank
and blank of each member of the team in
pursuit of our company blank and some
people have sold these in with different
sort of things a the first blank could
be assumptions beliefs values my
favorite is core values the second blank
for the be blank
people have said behaviors my favorite
sort of answer that is real action how
do you act an in pursuit of goals that's
kind of weak in pursuit of big and hairy
audacious goals that's a little stronger
but a better definition is in pursuit of
the mission so now that sort of we have
that definition what do we do with it
and why does it matter this is a quote
from Ghandi your beliefs become your
thoughts your thoughts become your words
your words become your actions and your
work your actions become your habits and
your habits becomes your values and your
values become your destiny if you don't
have a good culture in the company you
can't pursue your destiny why it matters
is it it becomes the first principles
that you sort of go back to when you
make decisions it becomes a way to align
people on values that matter to the
company it provides a certain level of
stability to fall back on and it
provides a level of trust that people
can sort of trust each other with it
also give you a list of things that you
should be able to figure out what to do
and what not to do and what the more
important thing about that is what not
to do and then finally the other thing
that is important is it allows you to
retain the right employees there are
people in this world are not going to be
a fit for your company but if you have
good strong culture and good strong core
values you'll know who you want to
retain and who we do not want to retain
and if you took to take the first words
a first letter of those it happens to
help you move faster
another reason you're thinking that's
like all mushy stuff
this is actually more scientific stuff
so here are indices for from 1997 to
2003 of stock market index of companies
in the S&P 500 in the Russell 3000 and
then for the fortune 100 best companies
to work for they survey all these
companies out there and they've picked
out companies that they believe are the
best companies to work for and the
returns the stock market returns of
those companies happens to be 11.8% 11
point oh eight percent which is home
twice that of the other two indices and
so there's real power in companies that
treat their employees well where there's
a lot of trust and what where there's a
lot of called strong culture so how do
you sort of create a set of values and
and sort of define the culture etc get
asked that a lot
you guys start with the leader of the
company the founder and sirs ask
yourself what are the personal values
that are most important to you one of
those things that are most important to
the business who are the types of people
you like working with and what are their
values and through that you sort of
distilled together what a set of values
are then think about all the people that
you've never liked working with what
values they have they've got the
opposite of that and maybe those should
be considered values for you for your
company and finally remember this the
values have to support your mission and
if it doesn't support your mission
you're missing something and then the
last final checks are they have to be
credible and they have to be uniquely
tied to your mission so add Zappos in
terms of uniquely applied to the mission
we're focused on creating a culture that
was going to provide great customer
service so the first core value we had
was to deliver WoW through service we're
very specific that we want to deliver a
customer service and was going to be a
while experience and then below that we
want to sort of add a paragraph
supporting that talking about exactly
what we mean by that want to support
them deliver well through service and
support people such as our employees our
customers and our brand partners and our
investors in terms of the opposite thing
we generally didn't like working with
arrogant people so one of our core
values that sapless was to be humble so
those are two examples where we sort of
created core values in a way that sort
of sort of became credible and uniquely
tied to our mission so you go through
this process you come up with a few core
values these might be some of them
whether it's honesty integrity service
teamwork and it might be a list of you
might start with three you might end up
with a list of ten might
list of 30 the good start and when's
appleís went through this process we
start with like we asked all the
employees at the time what core values
they want to identify list we came up
with 37 we initially sort of whittled it
down to that 10 and it took a year to do
this that's a long time and you might
want to ask why well if you just come up
with the word honesty I mean give me a
break
everybody wants the culture to be on it
now you nobody is going to say I want to
be lied to every day service what do you
mean by service there's got to be a lot
more depth in this than that and nobody
everybody talks about teamwork but
there's a difference in level of
teamwork that you see in an intramural
sports team as versus a baseball team
and so how do you sort of dive deeper
into teamwork what are the things that
don't work on for a team a lot of it has
to do with communications a lot of it
has to do with things that people have
studied and you might want to go deeper
into that Ed's appleís we thought about
well there are a lot of smart people in
this room when they're fighting with
each other and trying to figure out
who's right and who's not probably not
the best use of time and we want
everybody to sort of riff off each other
and help each other make any idea better
the result is that the company gets a
better idea not that any individual
person is right so we wanted to instill
this idea that it's company first then
your department then your team than
yourself and how do you do that loveable
deeper in that there's another there's a
great sort of sort of element of
high-performing teams that I really like
which is this pyramid that was created
by Patrick Lencioni and he wrote this
book the five dysfunctions of a team and
the reason this is interesting he talks
about the breakdowns of a teams first of
all if you don't a lot of teams break
down because they don't have any trust
then even if you had trust why do you
need trust well then if you have trust
you can actually have debates and
conflicts and get to the right answer
you don't have conflict and debate
people are just it's the blind leading
the blind how do you know you actually
got to the right answer before you sort
of commit to something so people are not
actually willing to commit they're
afraid of committing and so let's say
you get to the next level you are
actually able to commit well what what
goes wrong then it's usually because
people are not held accountable to
things that they committed to and if
people are not accountable to the things
that they've committed to then they
can't get resolved and I would submit to
you if you think about the company as a
black box and results whether it's
financial whether you produce a great
product or anything like that as the
output one of the major inputs is the
culture of the company so some other
best practices we're going to actually
talk about what during Q&A because I
think this is going to blend into the
conversation is that you want to
incorporate your mission to values we've
talked about that performance you got to
think harder deeper longer about your
values and you might initially think you
need to do one of the things that I
think a lot of companies don't actually
do is they interview for technical fit
or skill fit or competency not realms
but they don't actually interview for
the culture fit and what if someone will
actually fall believe and follow the
mission I think that's a big big no-no
like I think you can have the smartest
engineer in the world but if they don't
believe in your mission they're not
going to put the poor their heart and
soul into it and that's one of the
things that we're if you actually sort
of start thinking about culture from the
interview process to performance reviews
to making sure that the daily habits
you'll get a lot further with produced
with making a great culture the final
point I'm making a daily habit I think
culture just like customer service or
Fitness is like motherhood and apple pie
everybody wants to provide great
customer service every company wants to
have a great culture what they fail to
do is make it a daily habit you just
can't be fit if you're if you don't do
it as daily have it eventually you get
out of shape then you get fat and then
you're like oh I got to go on a crash
diet to sort of get back into shape that
doesn't quite work
and the same is true with something like
culture so I think we checked all of
these off so we can go into Q&A with
Brian all right hello everybody
it's quiet in here avianna no it's much
better now I feel a little less on edge
something works in like a room for
people really really quiet staring at
you but naturally I did it for 5-10
minutes yeah if it could bear for a
little longer exactly so Brian talked
about how the process by which you came
to understand the culture was important
to Airbnb and then building the company
yeah so um I think one of the things we
realized is so just to give you I won't
tell the full story of every being some
of you may know it but the very short
version the story was that Airbnb wasn't
meant to be like the company we were
trying to start I had quit my job I was
complete I was living in LA one day I
drove to San Francisco became roommates
with my friend from college I went to
renowned school design Joe Gebbia and I
had $1,000 at the bank and the rent was
one thousand one hundred fifty dollars
so that weekend this international
design conference is coming to san
francisco all the hotels was sold out we
this idea Alexis turned our house into a
bed and breakfast for the conference on
how many beds Joe had three air beds we
pulled them out of clause that we called
it the air bed and breakfast that's how
the company started I probably told that
story 10,000 times by the way some
version of that story and I didn't think
I've ever told that a second time when I
remember growing up I also went to
college and my parents were social
workers and they had kind of been
nervous about me going to art school
they kind of worried that maybe I would
like not get a job after college which
wasn't sure a lot of parents are worried
about you said make sure you promise me
you get a job a health insurance I ended
up starting air bed and breakfast calm
was original name she remember her
telling me I guess you never got that
job of health insurance the reason I say
this though is this Airbnb what never
meant to be the big idea it was meant to
be the thing to pay the rent
we can think of the big idea and along
the way by solving our own problem it
became the big idea
so alongside that I'm not going to talk
about like kind of how we built the
product up probably another conversation
that some other people are talking about
you have to build a team and a great
company and in the early days we had
three co-founders Joe Nate and myself
and I kind of think of one of the
reasons we're successful was I was
really lucky and I don't think I was
really lucky because we came up the idea
of Airbnb I don't think we're lucky that
we became successful once we had the
team I think we could have come with a
lot of ideas and been somewhat
successful I think I was lucky because I
found two great people that I wanted to
start a company with people I admire
that almost intimidated me how talented
how smart they were and I think that's
one of the first things you got to build
a team that is so talented that they
kind of almost make you slightly
uncomfortable because they know by being
with them you're going to have to raise
your game to be with them and then when
we were working together in the early
days is like 2008 the first thing is we
we were like a family you think about
founders founders are like parents and
the company's a child and the child will
manifest in many ways behaviors that
parents have between the relationship as
a parents are dysfunctional they're not
working together then the child's going
to be frankly pretty [ __ ] up and so
you don't want that you want your
culture to be awesome and so Joanie and
I were like total total family in the
beginning we worked 18 hours a day seven
days a week I number we were y
combinator
we like work together we like eat food
together we like even went to the gym
together we may have done jumpsuits we
didn't go that far but we were like it
was like we're a mission I felt like
we're like Special Forces or something
and we had this like amazing shared way
of doing things with amazing
accountability and then we realized that
was like the DNA of the company and then
we started thinking at some point you go
from building the product to Phase two
which is building the company that
builds the product and so a lot of the
talk is about how do you build a product
how do you get product market fit once
people start doing that now you've got
to build a company and it doesn't matter
how great your original product or idea
is that you can't build a great company
then your product will not endure as we
thought about this and one of the things
you realized we want to build a company
for the long term the last thing I want
is to build something I mean think about
it this way if you're if your company's
like your child a parent wants this
child that will live him or her
be a tragedy that live your child also I
felt like be a tragedy for us to outlive
our company and just watch it rise and
fall we didn't want that we wanted the
company that would endure and so to do
that we started noticing companies have
something in common
companies that were around for a really
long time had a clear mission and they
had a clear sense of values they had a
shared way of doing something that was
unique to them and was really really
special it's been Joey and I when we
were three people decided to look around
companies I know it's Apple you know
Steve Jobs talked about core value was
that he believed people with passion
could change the world and he said our
products changed but our value never had
and we learned about Amazon we learned
about Nike we learned about companies in
the early days you can even use this to
talk about organizations you know even
like a founding of a nation have strong
values in a declaration then the country
might endure longer if we started
realizing like we need to have intention
culture needs to be designed and that's
not how we got connected is because you
know we were funded by Sequoia after
them to just join from Zappos Sequoia
and I was told Zappos had an amazing
culture and we went to Las Vegas and met
up with Tony and we learned about it and
so what did you learn well you guys were
crazy
I defer the thing we learned and we were
three people what you need to have
cultures of shared way of doing things
there's really two parts one is
behaviors and those can kind of change
and maybe 50 years from now there will
be rituals and behaviors that will
change be different but there has to be
some things that never change some
principles some ideas then endure that
make you you and I think of core values
as integrity honesty those aren't core
values because their values everyone
should have their like integrity values
but there has to be like three five six
things that are unique to you you could
probably think about in your life what
is different about you then every single
other person if you could only tell
somebody three or four things what do
you want them to know about you and we
would realize that when Zappos is 100
employees they wrote down these nine
quarters anion 10 10 core values and the
only thing I learned from Tony's you
said I wish I didn't wait till I was 100
employee to write down a core value so I
think I was talking to Sam he says he
thinks were alone the only companies
that wrote our core values down before
we hired anyone how long did it take you
hire for employment so our first
employee was our first engineer and I
think we looked for him for four or five
months and I probably interviewed I
probably looked through thousands of
people and interviewed hundreds of
people and by then when you hire the
when did you write it did you write it
on day one or did you it was a month
three I think we started working on it
around the time of Y Combinator which
would have been January 2009 it was
probably a process they'd evolved over
the course of six to seven months we
finished Y Combinator in April 2009 I
think we hired a first engineer in July
something like this is probably like six
months and the reason some people asked
like why did you spend so much time on
like hiring your first engineer and
here's what we thought about it
I kind of felt like your first engineer
was like bringing in DNA to your company
this person was going to like there were
going to be if we were successful there
were going to be a thousand people just
like him or her in the company and so it
wasn't a matter of like getting somebody
to build the next three features that we
needed to ship for our users there was
something much more long-term and much
more enduring which was do I want to
work with one hundred or a thousand more
people like this now you want diversity
but you don't want you want diversity of
like beliefs you want diversity of like
background age you don't want diversity
of values you want a very very
homogenous beliefs and that's the one
thing that shouldn't be diverse so what
what our Airbnb values so we have six
core values I'll maybe talk about three
of them yes
so our first core value we talk about is
champion the mission and what it really
means is that we want to hire people
that are here for our mission we don't
want people here because they think
we've got a great valuation they like
our office design they need a job or
they think it's hot we want people to be
here for the one thing that will never
change in that's our mission and just to
tell you a quick story about our mission
you know Airbnb you know a lot of people
describe it as a way to book a room or
book a house and you travel around the
world and that's what we do but that's
not at all why we do it and to answer
the question of like what what our
mission is I'll just tell you a quick
story and this I think describes it in
early 2012 I met a host named Sebastian
so we do these meetups around the world
where you meet with hosts I meet this
host named Sebastian is probably like
late 50s
North London if the bastion look to me
says Brian there's this word you never
use in your website and I said what's
that word he said that word is
friendship I would love to tell you the
story about friendship I said okay tell
me the story about friendship he said
six months ago
the Rowan riots broke out outside my
home and I was very scared and the next
day my mom called me to make sure I was
okay he said yeah mom I'm okay
and she goes what about the house and he
says what yeah the house is okay as well
he said here's the interesting thing
between the time the riots broke out the
time my mom called me was a 24-hour
window time and in that period of time
he said seven on my previous aired movie
gets called me just to make sure I was
okay he said think about that seven of
my guests called me before my own mother
did I know that says about our guest
Rose mother more but but in in this
summer on a typical night or a peak
night we would have 425 thousand peeps
25,000 people staying in homes and
living together and they were coming
from 190 countries in the world which is
every country but North Korea Iran fear
in Cuba so when you hear that story at
our core what we're about that's much
more than just booking a room or
traveling what we are about is we want
to help bring the world together we want
to do that by giving a sense of
belonging anywhere you go so our mission
is to belong anywhere so five years from
now 20 years from now maybe we're still
selling rooms and home but maybe we're
not but I can guarantee you we're always
going to be about it's this sense of
belonging and bringing people together
and that's the more enduring idea so
when we hire people the first thing we
need to make sure is the fast our
mission you need to champion that
mission your champion the mission by
living the mission do you believe in it
do you have stories about it how to use
the product would you bleed for the
product I used to ask like crazy
questions like one of the a total crazy
question Sam reminds me of it I used to
interview people so I interviewed the
first 300 employees of Airbnb which
people think I'm like really neurotic
and that may also be true but um and I
used to ask him a question which I've
now amended I used to ask them if you
had a year left to live would you take
this job and actually the people who say
yes that you probably don't like if
that's like Bish's I spent time your
family so I amended it if it's 10
year because I feel like you should you
whatever if you knew yet ten years left
to live whatever you want what you would
do in those last ten years you should
just do and I really wanted people to
think about that that was enough time
for like you to do something you really
cared about and the answer doesn't have
to be this company and I say find it
what you're meant to do is to travel
we're going to do is start a company you
should just do that
don't come here go do that and so
there's this old kind of parable
probably many you've heard of it about
like two men or laying bricks somebody
comes up to the first man says what are
you doing is I'm building a wall he
asked the other guy what are you doing
cuz I'm building a cathedral there is a
job and then there's a calling and we
want to hire people aren't just looking
for jobs and looking for a calling and
that that's kind of the first value and
that's champion the mission I'll just
maybe because I want to take all the
time I'll talk about I'll talk about
just one more just so we don't talk
about things just I value the second
value relates to being kind of creative
and frugal and I'll tell you a story our
company was like by the way all the
founding stories of your company end up
becoming the things that people repeat
and talk about when you're a thousand
people and it kind of embodies right
it's kind of like your childhood these
things kind of come back later in life
same thing with the company so Airbnb I
think Marc Andreessen I said the last
talk that was like the worst idea that
ever worked and it really probably was
the worst I mean people were thought we
were crazy I remember telling people
about the idea and I remember actually
telling Paul Graham I said we have a
side in there an interview we said we
have idea it's called Airbnb he goes
people actually doing this I go yeah his
father was what's wrong with them so I
knew the interview wasn't going well and
in the interview at the end of the
interview Paul Graham I think wasn't
gonna accept us and but we told him this
story how he's funded the company and
here's how it goes we were introduced
Michael Seibel who I think is a partner
why cannot people know introduced me and
Joe to like 15 investors in the valley
including some of the ones that have
been here and all of them like said no
to the company they could have bought
10% a company for like 100 150 thousand
dollars they all said no they thought it
was a crazy idea no one ever stay in
someone's home so we ended up just
funding the company with credit cards
and you know those binders P kids is to
put baseball cards in so we put credit
cards in those
because we had to put them all somewhere
that's how many credit cards we had and
we were completely in debt and in the
fall 2008 we provided housing for the
Democratic and Republican National
Convention and we had this weird crazy
idea because we weren't really selling a
lot of homes basically Airbnb launched
in a year after we launched I think we
had a hundred people a day visiting our
website and we had like two bookings
which is generally bad kind of like
releasing a song in a year later like
three people listen to it every day like
probably not going to be a very popular
song so but I believe in it Joe Nate
believed in it but um and so we were
completely in debt we don't know what to
do and so we get this idea well we're
air bed and breakfast we're providing
housing for the democratic or republican
national conventions what if we made
like a collectible breakfast cereal for
like the Democratic National Convention
and we came up with Obama Barack Obama
themed cereal we call it Obama owes the
breakfast of change and then we came up
with a Republican theme CEO for John
McCain we found out who the captain
Navy's who came up with Captain McCain a
maverick and every bite and we had $0
and without any money we were able to we
try to call like General Mills and they
told us to like stop calling them or
they're getting restraining order so
that didn't work but we found a local
alumni of RISD he made a thousand boxes
of cereal for us and we ended up sending
them to prep and eventually within a
week we got a national television
national news we made 40,000 dollars
selling breakfast cereal and that the
year 2008 we made $5,000 from a website
and we made $40,000 selling the
breakfast cereal
and I remember my mom asking so are you
a serial company now and that wasn't the
bad part the bad part was the oddest
answer which was what he never yeah
technically ethically uh so but the
reason I tell that is our second core
value is to be a serial entrepreneur I'm
sorry for the cheesy title I'm sorry but
the zero entrepreneur and we really mean
is that we believe constraints bring out
creativity and when you raise like a
hundred million dollars suddenly all
that scrappiness it's easy to lose that
scrapping this is easier for people to
tell you you know I just need like the
fifty thousand dollar contract or I need
this or I need that and whenever
somebody is just being a little bit not
like frugal and not being creative or
they tell me they can't do something
I'll just take a box of cereal and like
even just the suggestion of Obama's
notes they need to be scrappy and frugal
and so again a lot of the founding DNA
your company becomes these values these
principles and so everyone knows if you
don't give a crap you shouldn't be here
and it doesn't mean you have to give a
crap it just means you have to be here
and you also have to be creative it'd be
like kind of like an entrepreneur super
scrappy and these are some the values we
learn cool so you guys should start with
us or thinking about questions when I
open up the questions from the audience
but I have a few more questions so this
all sounds nice the stories are great
people here are pretty skeptical group
it's a sea s Department just probably
left-brain yeah focus it feels like a
softy kind of right brain I'm like a
total phony story but how has having a
strong culture helps you make important
tough decisions well I think that having
it so here's the thing about culture the
three things they never tell you about
culture the first thing is they never
tell you anything in other words no one
ever talks about culture and no one ever
tells you you need to have strong
culture and so like there are tons of
articles about building a great product
as kinds of card was about like growth
and adoption and there's very few things
about culture it's a psyche mystical
thing that's like kind of soft and fuzzy
that's the first problem the second
problem is it's hard to measure and
things that are hard to measure often
get discounted and these are like two
really um
things but the third thing is the
biggest problem the biggest problem of
culture is it doesn't pay off in the
short term in fact if you wanted to in
one year build a company and sell it as
quickly as possible the number one piece
of advice I give you is funk up the
culture forget about it just hire people
quickly culture makes you hire really
slowly and makes you be deliberate about
decisions that in the near term can slow
progress it's kind of like putting an
investment into the company short-term
and so these are the things people never
tell you so it's really about building a
company for the long term and to endure
now some of the things about culture the
first thing is you need to like be very
clear about like what's unique to you
that you stand for once you do that you
need to make sure you hire people that
believe in that and so we interviewed
hundreds of people you need to make sure
that you hire and fire based on the
ideas these values and and you know one
of the things we do is we constantly
repeat over and over again so we
interview like when we interview we want
to make sure they're world-class and
they fit the culture so the first thing
I used to ask people I have at the end
of the interview sheet if you could hire
this is a functional question if you
could hire anybody in the world would
you hire the person sitting across from
you and if our Valluvar if our vision is
become like the best number of what we
do why aren't we hiring the very best in
the world so every single person is
meant to hire a person better than the
previous people you're constantly hiring
the raising the bar you're constantly
hiring world-class people then we have
separate people called core values
interviewers who aren't in the function
so if you're an engineer the core values
engineers value interviewers are never
engineers because we don't want them to
be biased and say oh I know how good
they are and they interviewed just for
values to make sure that people care
about the same thing and we've said no
to a lot of really great people because
we just didn't feel right about them
being with us long term so that's one of
the things I also think that maybe some
other examples of when we kind of had
hard decisions I haven't kind of in in
late - in mid-2011 we had this so we
were mostly in the United States and we
had this internet clone funded by these
guys called the Sam we're brothers and I
was anyone heard about these Sam were
brothers they basically
we make big clone yeah rocket internet
video in public and they basically copy
American websites quickly and they try
to sell back to you in if they don't if
you don't then they just try to so it's
kind of like putting a gun to your head
and so and they they had basically done
just a Groupon Groupon this point was
like the fastest growing company in the
world ever first coming to me two
billion dollars in revenue and then they
they stopped doing Groupon this is a
group under on top of the world and they
cloned us and we had 40 employees we
raised seven million dollars they cloned
us and they raised ninety million
dollars and in 30 days they hired 400
people and I was in they and they wanted
to sell the company and if they couldn't
they were going to like destroy us
around the world and the problem with
Airbnb is if we're not everywhere around
the world like a travel site not being
in Europe is like your phone having
email it doesn't actually work so we
were kind of in trouble and I we had
this conversation and there was a
pragmatic decision of should we acquire
them and then there is the like kind of
values decision the pragmatic one that
should have probably said buy them
because you can't risk losing
international so just guarantee you're
going to get international but we ended
up not buying them and the reason we
ended up not buying them is I just
didn't like the culture I didn't want to
bring in the 400 people I felt like we
were missionaries and they were
mercenaries I didn't think they were
doing it for the beliefs I thought they
were doing it to make a lot of money
very quickly and I believe in a war you
know missionaries would outlast now in
their mercenaries and I also felt like
the best revenge against an internet
start a internet clone was just to make
them run the company long term it's like
you had the baby now you gotta raise it
so that's what we end up doing and that
was a very controversial decision a lot
of people were telling me you should buy
this company we didn't and I think it
worked out let's say a lot for being how
what percentage of revenue comes from
Europe um more than 50 percent I think
it worked out yeah
alright look anybody have any questions
I can keep going yeah so one other
question one of the statement we had a
Zappos was that culture and brand were
two sides of the same coin yes
Airbnb has a great culture and also a
great brand you want to talk a little
bit about branding since that's it's
actually kind of a weak thing in Silicon
Valley we don't tend to
yeah Iran yes what I actually just said
the same omits like I think Silicon
Valley is not historically really strong
or we don't talk about culture and brand
very much they are too tied the same
coin so culture like to break the
principles and the beliefs you have
inside the company that you want people
to be aligned with long term and
whatever happens inside the company
eventually comes out you can't hold it
in and brand is really the promise
outside the company that everyone
identifies with and so I think having a
clear mission and making sure that you
know that mission and making sure that
mission comes through the company it's
probably the most important thing you
can do for both culture and values and
then the second thing you need to know
is that your brand the way people think
about you as a company is often decided
by your you know I mean your brand
evangelists are your employees if you
have a weak culture we often think that
like companies that hire employees or
people that are deeply passionate create
companies that customers are really
really passionate about and those the
companies have strong brands and so you
know Zappos had a really strong brand to
the strong culture and a lot of
companies of Google they care deeply
about the culture they say have a
question is this person googly and it's
meant to be like a catch-all for
addition to Google culture Google is a
very strong culture it's unique to
Google and by the way there's no such
thing as a good or bad culture it's
either a strong or weak culture and a
good culture for somebody else may not
be a good culture for you so I think
brand is incredibly important as well
and brand is really the connection of
you with your customers and so if you
have an incredibly strong culture this
could be a whole talk on brand like you
have a straily strong culture culture
then the brand will come through the
final thing to say about brand is a lot
of people they talk about their brand
they talk about what they sell so if
you're Apple one way of doing is say we
sell computers and like this new our new
screens are like larger and it's faster
and they talk about bits and bytes and I
remember Steve Jobs had this really
important talk where he said the way to
win this is 1997 he first came back
wasn't to talk about bits and bytes the
way to win is to talk about what we
value in Y our core values we believe
people passion can change the world
and that was how we introduced the think
different campaign and so Apple before
they have this huge Renaissance which
became the
valuable company in the world they did
the sink different campaign which is
basically saying and this is what we
believe in and if you buy an Apple
computer you're also saying I believe in
this too and there has to be I think a
deeper core belief and if that doesn't
happen you're a utility and the
utilities get sold on commodity prices
how did you know how the question is how
do you know how to communicate this to
the company the culture or the core
values or the employees to the outside
world the culture the values submit the
brand community does well so the
question is how do we communicate what
everybody does in early in the days what
we learned a lot because in the early
days we communicated like it's utility
we actually said Airbnb is a cheap
affordable alternative to hotels and art
we had a tagline to forget hotels save
money with Airbnb in overtime we felt
like that was I mean you know this is
really early days we felt like that was
way too limiting that is undercut the
idea and so we we then eventually change
our tagline to travel like a human which
we don't we haven't kept but it would
basically meant to say that like we
believe in a certain kind of world and
we really feel like travel is
mass-produced you feel like isolated you
feel like a stranger if we want to bring
the world back to the place where it's a
little bit like a village again where
the service is coming from other people
you have the feeling like you belong and
you're actually treated like a human you
know no matter how successful you are in
life often traveling we remind you
you're not that successful go through
TSA stay in a typical hotel sometimes
you'll have some problems we really want
to make people feel special and this was
kind of some of the stuff we did in the
early days we did a lot of storytelling
I mean you know I probably told the
story of Airbnb like 10,000 times and
this is something it's kind of relate to
culture but one that somebody asked me
other day like what's the job of a CEO
and there's a number of things CEO does
but what you mostly do is articulate the
vision so you like articulate a vision
you got to develop a strategy you got to
hire people to fit the culture if you do
those three things you basically have a
company and that company will pull
we'd be successful if you have the right
vision the right strategy and good
people so we end up doing is our
tickling division over and over and over
again whether you're hiring people or
recruiting them talking to investors
raise money doing PR interviews if
you're speaking at a class you're always
reinforcing the values you're doing an
email through a customer if you just do
a thousands of times and if you do
something thousands of times it will
change and get better every time so it's
just kind of evolved so those
interacting with the pose so harder and
also reinforcing the community very very
good question how do we make sure the
hosts are in the course in the culture
of Airbnb so when the the answer to that
is we do a pretty good job but not yet
an amazing job at it when we first
started Airbnb we I kind of took the
Craig Newmark school of thought Craig
Newmark the founder of Craigslist and I
said anybody should be able to use
Airbnb you didn't have to apply if you
want to rent your place we could rent
your place and it turned out that many
of the people believed in our values
because we talked about it and we
tracked them but there were people who
rented on Airbnb not because they
believed in value because they realize
they can make a lot of money running
their home and not everyone really was a
great culture fit and these people
actually did cause us a lot of problems
so that was actually a bit of a lesson
for me and I didn't think our hosts had
to I didn't really occur to me in the
early days the host had to completely
fit the values now we met them we
tracked people like us and so over time
we've realized hosts or partners and so
they need to believe in the same values
we do and so you know now we have a
program called a super host program
where they have to like demonstrate
values to reach this kind of badge which
gets them kind of priority customer
support and distribution we are having
this impulse convention where you bring
all the hosts in we're going to be
talking about and reinforcing the values
so the answer is like the answer is we
were really late but we now do it by
reinforcing it every step of the way got
some great competition local communities
the other awesome how's that
should be community culture on your own
yeah yeah I think just in general it may
be relative maybe related to two things
about Airbnb we tend to be a pretty open
culture just in general we communicate a
lot and we generally you know believe in
the idea of like a shared world where
people are giving back and contributing
making communities and industry stronger
so then just my one philosophy on
communication is we basically
communicate and talk about everything
internally except for things that relate
to employee or customer privacy so if it
doesn't really toes two things will
basically talk about it as far as open
source culture and engineering we wanted
to make sure that we had a really strong
identification of the team until we we
we really felt like a lot of source code
shouldn't be you know we felt like every
company needs a moat some kind of moat
that protects you from your competition
we thought some technology would be but
we also felt like we wanted to be able
to give back from a technology
standpoint and we preferred our moat to
be that we provide the very best
experience in the world when you use
Airbnb we have the biggest network
effect we sought that kind of took
precedent over having like you know you
know having like certain technology that
we only we could use and so we decided
to try to share some of that out people
and I think it does relate in its relate
to the values now one other thing is I
never reckoned I never one day
recommended this is the hopefully view
of strong culture like I didn't
recommend we at least we do any of that
we hired engineers that we fell accept
the values and it just independently
occurred to them they should do that
they felt like that was the right thing
to do all the way in the back
conventions you didn't have any money
you only come people to your site what
did you do to increase the number of
users who came to your site how did you
scale that up so the question was Brian
had talked about there weren't that many
visitors to the site when they were
trying to sort get off the ground how
did they get users to the site so this
is this is actually not about culture
but I'll answer anyway um so you know a
lot of people
the best advice this is not even a
culture question but the best advice I
ever got was probably from Paul Graham
pan Paul Graham basically said he mmbf
this line he said it's better he may
have or even talked about this talk but
he said it's better to have a hundred
people that love you then to have a
million people that just kind of sorta
like you it's literally better Navi will
love you and the reason why is if you
have a million customers or a million
users and they just kind of don't care
about you but they kind of use your app
and you're okay they get them to care is
a really really hard thing in fact I
don't know how to get a million people
to all of a sudden care boo I do know if
you get 100 people that love you those
people if they feel incredibly
passionate each of them will tell 100
people and in fact all movements
typically start or companies or ideas
that are really powerful start with just
a hundred people so the reason this is
so critical is he left gave us another
lesson which is if all you need to do is
get a hundred people to love you then
what you need to do is things that don't
scale so you know it's hard like if you
have a million people you can't meet all
them but you can meet a hundred people
you can spend time with them so that's
exactly what we did Joanna and I I mean
we would go toward a door in New York
City or in Denver where the Democratic
National mentioned was literally meeting
with staying within living with our
users I said Joe ket when you buy an
iPhone Steve Jobs income and sleep on
your couch but I did and that that was
like really critical like living with
your users and by living with our users
spending time with them all we had to do
is give them enough time attention and
get them to get a point where they were
deeply passionate and if you work
backwards from a hundred people or even
one person like without even technology
imagine what would be an amazing
experience for just this one person and
walk through the journey from the time
they like whatever your services right
and make it perfect for that one person
once you make a service perfect for one
person it's actually really easy to make
almost anything perfect for a person
it's not actually the hard the hard
thing is then how do we scale up to
millions of people where everyone gets
in trouble to try to solve both at the
same time so the first thing we do is
get the perfect spirit one person we
went door-to-door to do this we won over
their love then we use a separate kind
of part of a brain to imagine now how we
achieve that at scale and I'll give you
one example before
I stopped talking about it right now on
Airbnb you can if you put your home on
Airbnb you can click a button and a
profession it kind of works like uber
and we just before Burt that's
professional photographer comes to your
house and they'll photograph your home
for free we have 5000 photographers
around the world and we photographed
hundreds of thousands of homes so it's
probably one of the large on-demand
photography Network if there was such a
thing like it's probably only one but in
the world and that started with Joe and
I we were living what we were staying
outlet staying with this one host in New
York City and our house amazing but her
photos were terrible and we said why
didn't put up better photos and this is
before like you know iPhones a great
camera the 2008 I said I can't figure
how to get camera photos from this
camera onto this computer she wasn't
very technically savvy as you said well
we'll just take photo for you or I
actually I said what if you could press
a button and somebody just showed up at
your door and took professional
photograph should that be it magic so
next day I knocked on her door and said
I'm here and I photographed her home and
then we sent emails to people saying we
have this new magical photography
service and if you want you can press
this button in a professional
photographer will show up your home
similar presses button we just send me
alert or Joann alert we'd rent a camera
in Brooklyn in January 2009 walking
through snow photographing people's
homes we did this by hand without any
technology we managed it which is
spreadsheets I wasn't going to burn in
neat with trying to build something we
designed before we have photography then
we started hiring contract photographers
then eventually we got an intern to
manage all the contract photographers
then we got an intern to become a
full-time employee managing other
interns to manage the contract employees
and at some point this before we built
anything and at some point there were
too many like people to manage like
there were like hundreds of drivers and
then we finally built all the tools to
manage all the photography but we did it
only after we knew exactly what the
perfect service was one more question so
a lot of people say that when when is
the hardest part isn't as ecology
energy and welcome to say it's not going
somewhere in flight you know please so
you want to repeat the question so the
question is a lot of people in this
particular situation in therapy and be a
lot of people think that this is not
necessarily a technology company but
it's more of a marketing company good
question so I'll answer the question
with a story okay let me let me let me
just let me preface that question by a
set of questions you have three today
has proprietary technology do you have a
moat yeah
do you have network effective do you
have pricing power yeah do you have a
good brand I think so are you are you a
monopoly I'm not going to that
but but I think similar to the question
just forgetting about all of that it's a
company that have network effects and
sort of get off the ground if the
flywheel was going yeah people just
think that you're lucky let me let me go
it's a totally fair question and people
said it so an answer it you got it runs
the koi capital now his name is Doug
Leone yeah one day I think it's a year
year and a half ago Doug Leone says your
job sucks and I was like what the hell
does that need like this is like you've
got the worst job of any CEO and my
portfolio and I said tell me why and
this is what he said he says well let me
here's how I think about it first of all
you're a technology company and he
thought we were technology company I
would say at our heart in many ways we
are a technology company and so you have
all the challenges of all the other
portfolio companies but beyond that you
are in 190 countries and so you have to
figure out how to be international we
have to hire people in countries all
over the world we're literally in every
country about North Korea Iran Syria and
Cuba
Europe needs to be a payments company we
handle billions of dollars through our
system every year and we had to get
money transmission license in the state
of California so we actually are a
payments company we have serious fraud
and risk to warrant and needs to be
locked down like Fort Knox they said
that's that's usually where companies
end but you've got to work all the other
crap they said trust in safety you know
we have four hundred twenty five
thousand people staying and other
people's under in other people's beds in
their sheets think about a woman from
Texas things in the Middle East or vice
versa
the cultural conflicts that could happen
and misunderstanding and you know yeah
four hundred twenty five thousand people
a night it's like being the mayor of
Oakland now imagine if you're the mayor
of Oakland all the things happen Oakland
tonight so you got to ransom safety now
we have regulatory problems you know we
are in 34,000 cities every city has a
different law different rules and many
of them are written in a different
century before you had any technology if
you've got to deal with that then you've
got issues like search and discovery so
Google's got its brand about being
really important about search the thing
about search those usually five a
question you know Google could give me
forty thousand results but it's probably
clear that there's like one or two best
options for every
buddy so if I want to know a question to
win answer the Julie won best answer we
have 40,000 homes in Paris there is no
vest home in Paris for anybody in this
room so we have to be really really
great at matching people and technology
we have to be a company that's just you
know another example Facebook for
example is a digital product their
product is their website our product are
these experiences you have in the real
world so we're not just an online
product we have to be an offline product
and we need to transition from when
you're at in your app through cities and
these are just some of the examples why
technology design so basically this long
of the short of it is we have to be
world-class of Technology we see real
cost of design we'd be real cost at
branding because we've got to convince
people this isn't crazy you're not going
to die when you use it we had to
convince government this is good for
your neighborhood what happens the
internet moves into your neighborhood
that people call it it's a good thing
hopefully and you've got to make sure
trust and safety is really world-class
that we handle payments and not have
problems with risk and I can kind of go
through and this is not even to do with
culture I didn't even mention culture so
that's how I describe is like I think
great companies or companies are
probably really strong at everything but
you know we we try to hire the very best
engineers and technical talent in the
world and I definitely don't see it as a
marketing company thank you thank you
guys
[Applause]
you